I I feel like um it's already been like
answered, but there is a part of like
God's nature and why we were created.
>> Yes. Go ahead. Why we were created?
Okay, good question.
>> Yeah,
>> that one. Yeah, just don't let anyone
distract you. I'm going to go through
it. All right.
>> The Bible says God created out of love,
not out of need. Let me show you what
the Bible says about his nature. You
ready?
>> And let me show you what love is
according to.
>> All right. Let me Okay. Now, let me
explain to you why then there's evil.
Now, we're going to go through it
systematically for you. Alrighty then.
Here, God is love. Meaning, we only know
love because God is love. We only know
justice because God is just. Justice,
love, purity, holiness. We know these
things because God is the source of
these things. He is holy. He is just. He
is pure. In fact, let me show you that
real quickly before I go to the answer
to that question. All right.
Why do you need to be holy? Because God
who created you is holy. Why do you need
to be pure? Because God who created you
is pure. God created you to reflect his
character, his moral character.
Here, let me show it to you. Leviticus
11:44:45.
For I am the Lord your God. Consecrate
yourselves, therefore, and be holy, for
I am holy. So, why does he want you to
be holy?
Because he's holy.
>> Exactly. Why does he want you to be
just? Because he's just
>> shall not.
>> Amen. You shall not defile yourselves
with any swarming thing that crawls upon
the earth. For I am the Lord who brought
you up out of the land of Egypt to be
your God. You shall therefore be holy,
for I am holy. See, again, New Testament
Peter
1 Peter 1:15-16. But as he who called
you is holy. So the one who called you,
he is holy by nature. Be holy yourselves
in all your conduct since it is written,
"You shall be holy, for I am holy."
Right.
>> Yeah. Right.
>> So why do you demand justice? Because
the God who created you is just. Why do
you seek love? Why do women want to be
loved? Because God who created you is
love. And he created you in love and
gave you love as one of those
characteristics that define who you are
being in his image. All right. Now, with
that said, I can go on and give you
this. But here, he who does not love
does not know God. For God is love.
Where's John 4:8? See it?
>> Yeah.
>> Now, you're going to get your answer. He
who does not love. See, you cannot know
God if God is love and you be heartless
and cruel. The husband who abuses his
wife does not know God. And I'm going to
show you that even in scripture. 1 John
4:16:18.
So we know and believe the love God has
for us. God is love and he who abides in
love abides in God and God abides in
him. So if you say you know God, then
you've experienced God's love and God is
filling you with his love to love him
and others. But if you say you know God
and you don't love others, you're a
liar. You don't know God. God does not
have relationship with you. And this is
love perfected with us that we may have
confidence here. Here's the day of
judgment that you've been talking about.
>> Here's what God's love assures you. you
if you are his daughter that on the day
of judgment you have confidence he won't
damn you because you've experienced his
love. You've been filled with his love
and you've been walking in that love and
loving others. And that's a sign on the
day of judgment you'll be okay because
as he is so are we in this world.
Meaning God is love. So in the world we
behave like God. We were just like God.
We were holy like God. We love like God.
That's why you hate injustice because
God hates injustice.
So you behave like God in the world as a
witness to others. Now there is no fear
in love.
But perfect love cast out fear. So does
his children. If you truly know me and
you've experienced my love and you know
I love and adore you and want the best
for you and you accept that love and
you're acting in it, you have nothing to
fear when you stand before me. For fear
has to do with punishment and he who
fears is not perfected in love. So if
you are overfocused on judgment
and you're overfocused on punishment,
you need to be balanced. You're not more
just than God. And on the day of
judgment, those who don't know God, they
will be stricken with fear and terror.
But fear and terror is only for those
who are godless and don't know the true
God.
You got it?
>> Yes.
>> So, why did he create you? Out of love.
He didn't create you out of need. He
created you out of pure love. And here's
what true love is. By this we know love.
What is love? Someone says, "What is
love?" That he laid down his life for
us. And we ought to lay down our life
for the brethren. See, if I am of God, I
love the way God loves. And like Jesus
died for me out of love, I should be
willing to die for my family, meaning
whether your mother and father or
believers or for the child who's being
abused come to save that child. And if
it means I die saving that child, so be
it.
But if anyone has the world's goods, now
notice, if now I'm a Christian, and God
has blessed me financially,
and I see my brother in need,
struggling, yet closes his heart against
him, how does God's love abide in him?
Little children, let us not love in word
or speech, but indeed in truth. So what
is he saying? God is a God of action. He
doesn't just tell you he loves you. He
proves it. And what was the greatest
proof that God loves you? Jesus died for
you.
No greater proof could God have given
you when the eternal word became flesh
from the holy virgin voluntarily died to
show you this is how much I love you. I
die in your place so you can be spirit.
So then he says you Christians you must
love in action too. So if this sister's
in need and I'm financially well off I
don't help her. I am a liar because love
is action.
So, do you see what love is?
>> Yeah.
>> Now, let me show you how this reflects
with marriage and I'm going to give you
the answers. I got to go step by step
with you so you can get the answer. Now,
this is recorded. You can go back and
listen
>> so you don't forget the answers. Now,
here is
how Jesus being the spiritual husband of
the church. The church is the body. We
So, he's our husband, but it's not a
sexual relationship. Spiritual, but he
becomes the model. Watch here for
husbands. Ephesians 5:25-33.
Husbands,
love your wives as Christ loved the
church and gave himself up for her. You
will never find in the teaching of the
Quran or Islam where Muhammad says,
"Husbands, love your wives as Allah
loves you."
You ain't going to find that, will you?
>> But you will find 12 kinds of people
that he doesn't love.
>> Yep. But here Jesus is saying, and this
is Paul, by the way, who wasn't even
married,
>> who showed superior ethics and holiness
to Muhammad. He says, "Look, though I'm
not married, I'm Jesus ambassador." And
he says, "Husbands, you better love your
wives the way Christ loves the church.
And he loved the church that he's
willing to die for her, gave himself up
for her. Why? That he might sanctify
her, set her apart, having cleansed her,
making her pure by the washing of the
water of the word." Meaning when a
believer hears the word and gets
baptized, he or she now becomes his
bride that he might present the church
to himself in splendor. You're going to
be presented with glory. You're going to
be shining with beauty and majesty and
light. And you're going to be given a
crown because the Bible says you and I
will be kings and queens. It's in the
Bible. Says we are we will reign with
Christ as kings and queens without spot
or wrinkle or any such thing that she
might be holy and without blemish. So
even so husbands should love their wives
as their own bodies.
He who loves his wife loves himself. For
no man ever hates his own flesh, but
nourishes and cherishes it as Christ
does the church because we are members
of his body. For this reason a man shall
leave his father mother and be joined to
his wife and the two shall become one
flesh. Now he says the story of Adam and
Eve coming together as one flesh was a
picture of Christ the last Adam because
he became man. uniting to the church and
making the church one with him. This
mystery is a profound one and I'm saying
that it refers to Christ and the church.
However, let each one of you love his
wife as himself. Wow.
>> Marriages would be a taste of heaven on
earth if all husbands practice this.
Right.
>> Yes.
>> And let the wife see that she respects
her husband. So, it's it's a two-way
street. Wives, respect your husbands.
Don't disrespect them. Don't belittle
them. Don't insult them. And husbands,
love your wives to be willing to die for
them. Now, notice again, what's the
motivation? Love, right?
>> Yes.
>> So, what did God say? Love is action,
right?
>> Yes.
>> Because we read right here in 1 John
3:16:18, "Let us love not just in words,
right? But in deed and in truth." So God
being love
out of love wanted to create a creation
to experience his love
to demonstrate his love and fill them
with his love. So why did God create?
Out of love. That's the first part of
your question. Why did God create? I'm
going to repeat it again. He didn't do
it out of need. The Bible says he didn't
need anything. He did it out of love.
God wanted to create a creation
so that others could experience this
love and be filled with this love and
see that this God is in love with his
creation and his creation respond. But
there's a risk. Let me tell you what the
risk is. Okay? And it's going to all
make sense in light of the story of Adam
and Eve which the Quran parrots but does
not understand.
Because God is the example of pure love,
true love, we know love can't be
coerced. If someone makes you love them,
you won't love them, right?
>> Yeah.
>> If someone forces themselves on you, can
you love someone?
>> No.
>> So, if you have someone, a man who's
stronger than you, but then he forces
himself on you, forces himself
to make you his wife. and forces himself
to make you do what he wants. You may
externally show love but out of fear in
your heart you may pretend you love him
but in your heart you despise him.
Right?
>> Yeah.
>> See the problem with doing something out
of fear?
>> Yes.
>> That would be correct.
>> Yeah. Absolutely. I don't believe that
that's true love.
>> But God is true love. God is pure love.
God is perfect love. He cannot force
himself. God does not rape anyone.
So then if God creates out of pure love
and true love doesn't rape or force
anyone to then submit to the lover, that
means God will create beings with the
ability to choose.
Okay. Now you see the second step.
>> Yeah.
Because if he creates you and forces you
to love him and forces himself on you,
that's not true love. That's not pure
love. That is divine.
>> You're right. Yes.
>> Okay. But now someone can say, "Well,
hold on. What if God created you with
the impression you have free will, but
he designed you in such a way that you
can only respond to his love? So that he
deceived you into thinking you're freely
responding, but he programmed you in
such a way all you can do is respond and
you think you're doing it out of free
will. Could God have done that?
>> It could have, but I don't believe that
he did.
>> You know why he can't do it?
>> Why? Because God by nature is truth and
he can never be a deceiver. So if God
did that, that means he would know he's
acting in deception and that goes
against his nature cuz God cannot
deceive.
>> Oh wow.
>> So no, he couldn't do that. Let me show
you. Cuz God cannot lie. God cannot
disown himself. God cannot be tempted
evil. So that means if God created you,
then God would know he's acting
deceptively. He's a deceiver. The Bible
says God is truth. He is pure truth and
cannot lie and cannot deceive. So he
couldn't do that either.
>> I lived my entire life thinking that he
could do all good and all evil at the
same time.
>> That's why the Allah Muhammad is not the
God of the Bible.
>> Yeah.
>> Let me show you that God can't do that.
You ready?
>> Yeah.
So he can't do that because he know he'd
be lying and being dishonest to himself.
And God by nature cannot lie, cannot be
evil. God is truth, right? God is holy.
God is pure and God is just. So he
couldn't do that. He couldn't create you
into thinking you're responding freely
knowing that he was deceiving you. Here
it is. Hebrews 6:17.
Hebrews 6:17. So when God desired to
show more convincingly to the heirs of
the promise the unchangeable character
see it's unchangeable
of his purpose he interposed with an
oath he swore by an oath and God cannot
lie so that through two unchangeable
things see in which it is impossible
that God should prove false. So is it
possible for God to lie and deceive?
>> No
>> impossible right?
>> Yes. we who have fled for refuge might
have strong encouragement to seize the
hope set before us. And now again, Titus
1:2, in hope of eternal life, which God
who never lies. Why? Because what did it
say? It's impossible that he could lie.
Never lies. Promised long ago. That's
why we can trust him.
Now watch. If he if we are faithless, he
remains faithful. Why? He cannot deny
himself. See, God cannot go against his
nature. He cannot go against who he is.
So if God is truth, Jesus says, I am the
truth. Can he be untruthful?
>> No.
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah.
>> And then here again, James 1:13, let no
one say when he is tempted, I am tempted
by God. For God cannot be tempted with
evil, and he himself tempts no one. So,
can God be tempted to evil and do evil?
>> Well, no. No, he can't.
>> So, now God is left with two options,
right?
>> Either he does not create
or if he creates being pure love, he has
to create beings with the ability to
choose knowing that by giving them
choice, there will be some who say, "We
don't want your love. We don't want you.
We don't want to submit to you. And
hence, evil is brought into the world.
Yes.
>> You understand why this was the world he
created?